un bateau petite photo ac non je pars
partir points ou autre chose au
calendrier du pipole photo de classe
tout ce que tu veux plus de guerre
c'est bonjour tu vas faire de nous des
bzd pourquoi si nous pouvions prendre en
photo parfois ça manque d'être ici je
vais garder une trace alors dépêcha de
photographier tous à marco pascal et
deux tiers c'est comme les ours blancs
ça bientôt disparaître et ailleurs les
gars sont prêts à travailler pour les
quarts d'un de salaire encore quand ils
prennent pas ici pour nous prendre notre
boulot enfin l'ami d'enfance c'est à
dire qu'il a voté fn aux dernières
élections comme histoire d'amour ce que
j'aime c'est l'absence la présence mes
frais allez expliquer ça la femme que
vous aimez
très profondément dans notre moi c'est
pas possible libé béni maison schmidt a
peur mais ça n'excuse pas tout
c'est en train de faire du mal je sers
tu crois cours qui vont sauver chantier
environ tous les étrangers sont tes
potes à ta gueule c'est l'on ne sent pas
ton discours de parisiens là ça va tu
vis plus il sait plus comment ça se
passe à viens pas me donner des leçons
chez moi d'accord
toi
tout est mis avec toi que son